local unions say they're still waiting
for ccsd to present a plan for a vaccine
mandate thank you for joining us at four
i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
cassadas it's been one week since the
school board voted to pass this
resolution kate houston is live where it
stands right now kate good afternoon
yes good afternoon one union i spoke to
says that they're really in a holding
pattern right now as they wait for the
district to formally reach out at this
time they don't have a timeline for when
that mandate could take effect and i
spoke to two out of the four unions
within the school district tonight the
teachers union will meet with some of
their members the ccasape which
represents administrators says they've
also met with their representative
council one concern from principles is
losing staff before they're able to come
up with a solution
we want to see what the district stance
is on people who have recovered from
covid and also what that exact data is
out there with numbers of infections
that have occurred
district-wide which doesn't seem to be
updated accurately at this point can you
give us an update on the vaccine mandate
and when you might present something to
the union
well i tried to get an update from
superintendent jara during a school
appearance today he walked away and
refused to answer my questions a
representative says they have reached
out to the unions and communication is
ongoing they will release a plan once
negotiations are done well school board
trustee linda cavazo says that she's
received multiple online threats since
that special meeting last week ccsd
police tell me they have many detectives
on this they've also submitted a
subpoena to social media companies to
try to get as much information as they
can reporting live from the clark county
school district kate houston 8 news now